as we're having this conversation i'm
sort of thinking that
like let's say it's the case that we as
human beings are just getting all kinds
of things wrong and that we're so
self-destructive right now we're just um
we're blind
we are um controlled by our fear of
ostracization
we are terrified of being labeled
heretics and cast outside of the group
we want desperately to belong to
whatever this
collectivist do your part sort of system
mentality is
and that's causing an awful lot of harm
it seems
why are we doing that you know and as a
as a student of history i can't help but
think of
ancient tragedies
you know and and a tragedy we use that
term i think loosely and improperly now
to refer to any sort of disaster but a
tragedy
technically speaking is one in which
there's a character who has your
protagonist or hero
who has a character flaw that forces him
to make choices that ultimately lead to
his downfall
so i feel like
we are
living a tragedy now and that we are as
a
this group of humans at this moment
in history
we are this protagonist that has
a maybe more than one tragic flaw
blindness or myopia sort of one of them
right we're focused only on
um
one kind of threat one kind of harm
um and only one escape route out of it
and we're willing to vilify
cancel
d platform kill maybe
anyone who challenges it
right
and in the process of doing that we are
quite possibly leading to our own
self-destruction and
if the ancient playwrights are right the
only thing that solves that kind of
tragic flaw is self-reflection
but we often can't i mean the tragic
heroes
they never get it until the end of the
story they need to things need to become
extreme that tragic flaw needs to play
itself out until the point of
destruction
where that person has lost everything
um they've lost family members maybe
they've even died themselves but usually
not right usually it's destruction of
all persons around him or her they've
lost their city they've been blinded
whatever it is and then
it's only that level of destruction
that puts us into a place where we are
left with nothing else but to consider
how we've gotten ourselves here
[Music]
you